[Music]  workers who were sent temporarily in  another EU country should get equal pay  for equal work at the same place members  will vote on new rules for posted  workers subsidized imports should not  flood the EU if they threaten businesses  and jobs  aside from boosting tariffs Parliament  is updating the anti-dumping rules to  better protect citizens members are  calling for mileage records of all  secondhand cars to be stored on an EU  wide database they're pushing for  tougher measures to fight odometer  tampering the position of EU farmers and  the global food system should be  strengthened members call for a modern  efficient and sustainable Common  Agricultural Policy host 2020 members  continue their exchange with EU leaders  on the future of Europe Prime Minister's  a V a Patel of Luxembourg comes before  Parliament's to debate on the issue  [Music]